[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous à la vie de
lézard aux caraïbes
la plage le soleil et les ouragans à
l'automne 2017
des chercheurs d'une collaboration
franco-américaine sont allés aux
caraïbes pour étudier la population
d'analystes script us un petit lézard
que l'on trouve dans l'archipel turques
et caïques hausse et dont l'activité
principale est de faire des ponts à
l'origine les chercheurs étaient sur
place pour voir si la dératisation des
il avait un effet sur la population de
ces petits lézards roi du fitness
mais l'histoire on a décidé autrement
quatre jours après leur départ des îles
l'ouragan irene a frappé l'archipel avec
des vents de 265 km heure suivi deux
semaines plus tard par l'ouragan maria
avec des vents de plus de 200 kilomètres
heure vous imaginez deux ouragans
particulièrement violente qui viennent a
ravagé tout pile votre zone d'étude
c'est la loose et bien non pas la loose
du tout au contraire les scientifiques
ont réalisé qu'ils avaient là une
occasion inespérée de mesurer les
conséquences de l'ouragan sur
l'évolution d'une espèce isolé
[Musique]
il a déjà été montré que les épisodes
climatiques l'ont tels que les périodes
de sécheresse ou les périodes glaciaires
sont responsables d'une sélection
naturelle mais qu'en est il des ouragans
c'est vrai qu'à priori un événement
aussi rapides et violents devraient
décimé la faune sans distinction les
chercheurs sont donc retournés sur
l'archipel quatre semaines plus tard et
en trouver une population d'à nos les
scripts us décimée
ils ont alors mesurer les survivants
sous toutes les coutures et ont comparé
leurs résultats avec les mesures prises
avant les ouragans et les changements
morphologiques sont flagrants les
survivants sont plus petit ils ont des
coûts s'ils la désirent plus large des
pattes avant plus longues mais aussi des
pattes arrière plus courte
ces lézards s'agrippent aux branches
grâce à de petites ridules sur leurs
coussinets donc avoir de larges qu'au
ciné apporte clairement un avantage pour
résister aux vents violents
mais comment expliquer la prédominance
des autres caractéristiques physiques
chez les survivants
c'est là que nos astucieux scientifiques
ont eu l'idée d'un dispositif de terrain
pour étudier le comportement des lézards
face à des vents violents
un anémomètre une tige en bois pour
simuler une branche le tout face à un
souffleur de feuilles mortes
les lézards sont soumis à des ventes de
0 à 175 kilomètres/heure filmé avec une
caméra ultrarapide
on voit que le premier réflexe de nos
rois du fitness n'est pas de s'enfuir
mais de se placer face au vent derrière
l'avant et de se coller à celle ci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
leurs pattes arrières l'achetant premier
puis très vite les lézards sont emportés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des pattes avant plus longues permettent
de mieux a grippé la branche et des
pattes arrière plus courtes réduisent la
prise au vent les lézards présentant ses
caractéristiques physiques pourraient
donc avoir eu un avantage évolutif
rassurez-vous le dispositif comprend
aussi un petit filet et de la mousse
pour réceptionner délicatement les
lézards ils ont tous été relâchés dans
leur environnement naturel sain et sauf
[Musique]
cette étude donne ainsi un résultat
préliminaire mais elle montre déjà que
les ouragans pourraient constituer une
pression de sélection et redéfinir
l'évolution des espèces sur leur passage
alors que les épisodes climatiques
extrêmes sont amenés à se multiplier
il pourrait avoir un rôle à jouer dans
les modèles actuels d'évolution des
espèces
voilà donc ya pas de lézard cette
recherche est bien une petite tempête en
sciences de l'évolution
n'hésitez pas à commenter et partager
cette vidéo je vous rappelle que vous
pourrez trouver toutes les sources dans
la description et abonnez vous